hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another video edition of ask Evan in
this video I want to answer questions
from one of my readers Hubert who asked
me what my favorite sales and marketing
book is so I read a lot of books are in
a lot of blogs i read a lot of articles
and trying to share with you guys when I
can and write that one of my favorite
sales and marketing books is called the
Fred factor x marks and boy and the
front factor is about getting more
referrals and I'm a big believer and
trying to get referrals for your
business if you make your customers
super happy they're going to want to buy
more from you and also introduce their
friends and family to you so they can
buy from you as well and get the same
experience that they have the Fred
factor is about a male man named Fred
and a resident in Fred's mail route
named mark who's the author of the book
and it's about the great service at Fred
provides mark that's way above what you
would expect from a regular mailman so
as an example when Mark first moved into
the neighborhood Fred knocked on the
door introduced himself and welcome to
into the neighborhood and so what was
the last time you post mended that view
then write notice that mark was often
away he wasn't in his house a lot of
times in the mail started adding up and
he knocked out door again and talk to
mark and found out that mark was a
speaker and was usually out of town and
asked for mark schedule so that he would
know when who was in town and he would
hold the mail for him until he came in
back in town so that's way about what
you'd expect from a regular mailman and
there's on and on and on stories about
what Fred does to really stand out and
he loves his job and you love servicing
his customers and those result gets a
lot of praise from the people in his
area so the same lessons can be applied
to your business I'm looking for
different ways you can really stand out
servicing customers and try to help them
as much as possible and love what you do
and if you do that they'll buy more from
you they'll be more loyal there they'll
refer a lot of friends and family on to
you and it's a great book to kind of
inspire you to why to help out a little
more to generate a little bit more for
your business so again it's Fred factor
it is just over 100 pages so really
quick read and I would definitely
recommend it for any entrepreneur trying
to increase their sales and marketing
efforts this year so I hope that helped
you break if you like the video please
give it a thumbs up your love will make
more just like it and it also love to
hear your thoughts and feedback if you
want to leave a comment below the video
and stay tuned for the next episode
you
you